in Edinburgh a long-running campaign for
the Melville monument to better reflect
the reality of the cities links to
slavery as fast gaining momentum efforts
to add a plaque spearheaded by a
professor Jeff Palmer of heriot-watt
University have finally been confirmed
after some two years and he joins me now
thanks very much for being with us and
we'll talk about the Melville Monument
in a moment I know you've been taking
part in the black lives matter protest
did you support the toppling of the
slave traders statue in Bristol well
they're very much aware of the statue
and I knew you know I know that they
were debating about putting a plaque or
to revise the plaque and that took a
long time and when it was toppled I
thought you know that was almost
inevitable because of the anger in
Bristol which I knew about and also the
death of George Floyd I think combining
the frustration in Bristol and the
social conditions plus the death of this
young man
I think precipitated it so I I was a
surprise but I'm not a supporter in
removing issed Oracle the monuments but
but isn't the destruction of a statue an
attempt to consign it and all it
represents to history and isn't that a
good thing in a way well I don't know
what that goodness would me because once
the statue has come down what you do
next if in fact the social conditions
are made the same
and what I'm concerned about is in a
hundred years you look back and somebody
said who was ghosted and therefore I
think removing history is one should
consider it very careful carefully and
you know for example
if you take a street name down and you
put something else up I think it's a
slow remove as a slow removal of history
and part of that is black history and
somehow what I would prefer is for a
plaque to be put up and the plaque
should have no-holds-barred if somebody
was responsible for killing you know 50
slaves or a hundred slaves or a thousand
slaves that should be on the plaque
so keep soapy please sorry to interrupt
so keep the statue no problem but attach
a gesture plaque putting what that
person did in a different context it or
in the real context if you like
absolutely and I think part of the
problem in our society if you look at
newspaper articles or if you look at the
protest that is taking place at the
moment and you tend to get and people do
it without even knowing they are if they
always try to produce what they call a
balance and you know if somebody killed
50 slaves then that should be on it but
if he gives you know a thousand pounds
to some charity that shouldn't be on it
and I think that what is caused is so
much problem over the earth is this
concept of balance and I think that if
we had plaques which actually told the
historical story in terms of the evil or
the cruelties that these people did then
I think he would have a better reaction
to the plaque and that's how I view the
and redundancy statute in Edinburgh yeah
so so the Dundas statue in Edinburgh I
mean now he the guy he delayed the
abolition of slavery am i right in
saying that that's what he did
effectively and so what sort of word did
you put on your plaque and
I guess then you're you could reach the
stage where people just disagree with
what the form of words are that you put
on on the plaque well we had a committee
which ran for over two years and we
debated you know what should be on the
plaque the original plaque that was on
on the statute only you know you talked
about all is the grand castle political
positions yeah you know he was you know
a control war and the Navy you know he
ran the colonies he selected the
governors so other than the prime
minister Pitt he was the most powerful
politician in Britain now the point is
that I want on the plaque that his
involvement in slavery that he caused
the gradual abolition of the slave trade
for 15 years he actually frustrated
Wilberforce for 15 years and I believe
that should be on the plaque that he
gradually gradually I will abolish the
slave trade and when you look at the
time like the politicians Pitt and Fox
those guys are giants of British
politics Pitt described Dundas is
gradual us you know refusing to act
until a thousand favourable
circumstances unite that was what they
all knew it meant and therefore for us
to debasing it in debating it in 20 you
know 1819 and a couple of my colleagues
did not want slavery on the plaque and I
refuse to accept that and therefore we
arrived at an impasse and the council a
couple of days ago actually said well
that committee now he's dead and we're
not really going to do anything anymore
and what the sudden change is because
the public so you know what was going on
with George Floyd they saw what was
going on with all the stuff we were
putting up on Twitter about
then redundant seas past he not only
delayed the abolition of the slave trade
the attacks on Domingo Haiti and he lost
40,000 British troops you know he got
the governor's to in Jamaica say the
governor there to transport the Maroons
to Nova Scotia
so but he did it what my colleague says
he did it because he was making money
for Britain so what's the big deal
well so would you be fishing out the the
Colston statue from from Bristol docks
and put it back on the plinth and then
put a plaque on explaining you know what
this this guy represented would you
would you be thinking about doing that
it could be probably very difficult to
do and I you know I hope because I don't
think they can put it back in terms of a
state state I said so they can probably
put it in a museum but I'm very
concerned for example if they if the
authorities to decide they're gonna melt
it down because somehow you know there
may be racist in our system who want
these things to be removed because they
see it as a part of my history and they
cannot bring themselves to write a
blackboard so somebody may want a street
name removed because he doesn't want to
put a plaque there to say that guy
killed a hundred black people as slaves
and that's where I feel that we got to
be very careful you can remove the
statues remove the plaques what do you
do about the stately homes that in fact
were built on slave money so somebody's
got to think this through carefully yeah
and what I'm trying to do here and with
my colleagues is to put a plaque on
Dundas a statue and over that this has
taken three days and the meeting this
morning in one hour
we actually prepared a draft in one hour
yeah and just just finally would you be
there are people want to tear down the
Cecil Rhodes statue now in Oxford you
what would your message be to people
who wanted to bring that down and other
statues maybe around the country I would
say to them I would say to them remove
the evidence you removed the deed remove
the evidence you remove the deed and I
would prefer that statue to remain where
it is but put on that statue exactly
what he did and what we don't have to do
is to make sure this is taught in
schools and universities and that in
fact we can use these history taught
truthfully and I believe that this will
help to change attitudes and it will
also give people a sense of belonging
surprisingly because without a sense of
belonging people don't exist well in a
society and therefore what race is do is
to try and damage your sense of
belonging thus we've got to teach
history to make sure the black people in
this country of a sense of belonging so
they can compete and have representation
which in fact will allow them to take
part in the society and not be seen as
the other because they're black okay so
Geoffrey Palmer interesting stuff thank
you very much indeed for joining us
thank you thank you